hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar changes to usp
643 total organic carbon from
pharmaceutical
grade waters i'm susie valdez of lab
roots and i will be your moderator for
today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by beckmann
coulter life sciences
to learn more visit beckman.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting as many questions as
you have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker tony
harrison
a senior marketing manager at beckmann
coulter life
sciences tony welcome you may now begin
your presentation
thank you very much for that
introduction i appreciate it and welcome
to everybody
today's short presentation on on the new
chapter
for the usb 643 on total organic carbon
uh my name's tony harrison i am a senior
manager at beckman quarter life sciences
so a revised version of the usb chapter
on toc
total organic carbon the usp 643 chapter
it's been published already uh but it
will become official on the 1st of may
uh this year 2021. this presentation
gives an overview
of this new document and discusses the
difference also
uh in the system suitability test
materials specified
in usb 643 and those specified in the
japanese
pharmacopoeia for toc
now total organic carbon is one of the
four
critical quality parameters defined by
the farmer computers for bulk purified
water
water injection water hemodialysis and
pure
steam condensate plus of course packaged
sterile waters
the other three are conductivity
microbial colony forming units
and endotoxins
usp 643 points out that toc
is an indirect measurement of organic
contamination
and that wealth tfc can be a food for
microbes encouraging their proliferation
in water systems
there's no direct numerical correlation
between toc levels in a water system
and microbial contamination levels
it goes on to state that toc can be
introduced to a bulk water system from
the source water
from the purification and distribution
systems
and from biofilm growing in the system
for packaged sterile water an additional
source of toc
can be the packaging itself
usb 643 states that toc is a limit
test and that means that the levels of
toc in a sample
must not breach the defined limit which
is the response of the toc analyzer to a
500 ppb standard
made up from usb traceable sucrose
so in other words whatever the toc
result the analyzer gives in response to
testing the usb
traceable 500 ppv carbon sucrose
becomes the maximum limit of toc
allowable in the water system
so the limit may not be a reported
result of 500 ppb of toc
and users should be aware of this and
ensure that the measured toc levels in
their water systems
does not exceed the limit reported by
their toc analyzer
when analyzing the 500 ppb carbon
usb traceable sucrose standard just
as an example if the recorded toc result
from the
toc analyzer in response to analyzing
500 ppv sucrose
is a to toc result of 450 ppp
then a reported toc result from a water
sample of 450 ppp
becomes the maximum allowable level of
toc for their water sample
not 500
now usp 643 does not mandate the
measurement technology it should be used
to measure toc
just that whatever is used should have a
manufacturer's specified limited
detection
of 0.05 milligrams per liter which is
equivalent to
0.05 ppm or 50 ppb
now that it should pass the test for
suitability
the system suitability test usp 643
states that the analyzer should meet
measure the toc by
oxidizing the organic molecules to
produce carbon dioxide
and then measure the carbon dioxide from
the toc to calculate the amount of toc
present in the water sample it does not
mandate
on or offline instruments but it goes on
to state that any technology used to
measure toc in water
must be capable of discriminating
between the toc
and the inorganic carbon maybe already
be present in the sample
total inorganic carbon it's called such
as dissolved
carbon dioxide that may be already
present in the sample or bicarbonate
now this discrimination can be achieved
either by purging the tic from the
sample before
oxidizing the organics or by measuring
the tic in the sample
and then subtracting that from the final
total organic carbon measurement
made after all the organics have been
oxidized to carbon
dioxide total carbon so
some analyzers measure tc and tic
through the mass and calculate
toc and this is perfectly acceptable
according to the usp
now when the toc test was introduced in
after the united states farm
here in 1998 it replaced several of the
tests
and the challenge was to ensure that
instruments used for trc analysis
would be suitable for analyzing the
range of organic compounds
expected to be found in pharmaceutical
grade waters
the system suitability test was
introduced as a method to verify
that a toc analyzer could analyze with
equal efficiency
a solution containing the relatively
easy to oxidize substance sucrose
as well as a solution containing the
longer chain and more difficult to
oxidize substance benzoquinone
both solutions must contain 500 ppp of
carbon
and a toc analyzer must analyze both 500
ppv solutions
equally well and produce toc results
from both
that when within plus or minus 15 of
each other
now i stated earlier the toc test is a
limit test
with a maximum allowable level in bulk
pharmaceutical grade waters
of 500 ppb of carbon now whatever
the toc result the analyzer gives in
response to testing that usb traceable
500 ppv
sucrose solution becomes the maximum
limit
of toc allowable in the water system so
the limit may not be 500 ppb
and as i said earlier users should be
aware of this
and ensure that the measured levels of
toc in their water
does not exceed the limit response
reported by their toc analyzer
when analyzing that 500 ppb sucrose
started
now this section here the system seems
to be suitability testing for packaged
sterile water
this is where the substantive changes to
usb 643 have occurred
in addition to passing the system
suitability test with the same plus or
minus 15
limit it now allows for different
concentrations of
toc depending on the container size for
the packaged water
and this is called l1 and as long as the
water sample being tested contains less
toc than
l1 it is deemed to have passed the test
and its
test is complete if however the reported
toc value from a water sample is higher
than
l1 but lower than the second defined
higher limit
l2 the user is required to determine
exactly
what organic compounds are present in
the water
using a suitable analytical procedure
if the quantity of every organic
compound present
measured individually is less than 0.2
milligrams per liter which is less or
equal to
0.2 ppm or less than equal to 200 ppp
then they are deemed not to be present
in a quantity that may be harmful to
patients safety
if however any individual organic
compound is found to be present in
quantities
greater than 0.2 milligrams per liter
then
that organic compound must be evaluated
for their impact on patient safety
at that reported concentration
if it's determined that there's no
impact on patient safety
then the water sample meets the
requirements and again the test is
complete
now if however any organic compounds are
identified as potentially harmful
and are present in sufficient
concentration to impact
patient state safety then the water
sample does not pass the test and fails
additionally if the toc analysis from
the water sample shows that the level
is higher than the second limit l2
then again the sample does not pass the
test and there's no requirement to
identify
and quantify individual organic organic
compounds
however of course the user may require
them to do this as part of their root
cause investigation but it's not
mandated
uh in islamic appeal
so this is the um the different package
uh the water container volumes that the
usb new usb
chapter uses less than equal to five mil
greater than five mil and less than
equal to 100 mil
and then greater than 100 mil and you
can see there's two limits
for toc l1 l2
and limit l1 is the first one as long as
it's below that
then the the past is a pass
if it's higher than l1 lower than l2
that's when you have to analyze
to determine what organics are present
and in what quantities
and are they harmful for patients if not
you pass great if however the test
company
comes with a result higher than l2
in the first place then it fails
and those maximum limits vary
according to the container size as you
can see
by the table and just the point of
interest the l2
limits are actually 50 percent higher if
you look at the table then
those are the l1 limits
so i did mention i'd comment on the
differences between the united states
pharmacopoeia
and the japanese pharmacopoeia on toc
now unlike usp 643 chapter
which is primarily aimed at
pharmaceutical waters
the japanese chapter on toc is a more
general chapter
and includes also reference to toc
analyzers
that are used for cleaning validation
too
and that's a fundamental difference so
as the organic compounds found in
cleaning rinse waters
may be more complex and difficult to
oxidize molecules
than those expected in pharmaceutical
waters the japanese
pharmacopoeia chapter on toc calls for
the toc analyzer to be challenged
with the solution of the ionic
surfactant
sdbs
so it's typical an ionic surfactant it
could be used in the cleaning process so
if they they expect you to be able to
analyze sdbs
now another difference is that the
japanese chapter gives
some guidance on calibration which is
not the case with usp643
the japanese chapter instructs the user
to use khp
as a calibration solution now khp is a
relatively easy to oxidize solution it's
very stable
and it's frequently used to calibrate
calibrate general purpose laboratory toc
analyzers
in contrast usp 643 does not specify how
a toc analyzer should be calibrated
nor what the calibration solution should
be made from but frequently
users will calibrate their toc analyzers
used to measure toc
levels in bulk waters water for
injection purified water
and they'll use calibration solutions
made up from sucrose because
that is the reference material specified
us by usb
643 to determine the toc analyzer's
maximum limit
for toc in both quarters
so this is bringing me to the end of my
uh presentation today
and in conclusion um i'd like to draw
parallels
between this new uh usp643 chapter
and the subvisible particle
contamination in parental drugs testing
chapter usp 788 where for small volume
containers the pass fail criteria
is based on the total number of
particles per container
and the change the test for packaged
sterile water and usb 643
is suggesting that the total amount of
organic carbon per container
is also a measure of patient safety not
just keeping toc levels between
below effect concentration as it would
be in bulk quarters
it is also asking users to do further
testing
when certain levels of toc are breached
to identify
each organic compound in the water to
better understand the risk to patients
now this is a significant change and it
will hopefully bring improved confidence
that sterile packaged water is safe for
human use
so thank you for intending uh sorry
attending today i'll now take
any questions that you have
and thank you tony for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you would like
to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's take a look it looks like we
already have some
great questions coming in
our first question from an audience
member says thank you for your
presentation
please explain one more time why the
maximum
level of allowed for packaged
sterile waters is so much higher than
for
purified water and water for injection
great thank you very much for your
question and thanks for attending so
um just to go over that again the usp
chapter
acknowledges that whilst there are water
is derived from either purified water
or water injection it's most likely that
there will be
additional toc contamination from the
container now
that's either because it's a toc is
present in the container when it's
filled
or another way it gets in there is
because these waters tend to leach
ions from the plastic or glass container
because they're actually
very aggressive reagents and remember
sterile waters usually undergo some sort
of final sterilization process
step so the presence of toc or higher
levels of toc
is unlikely to encourage bacterial
growth because any bacteria
should be either dead or sterilized
thank you so much our next question
please
can you explain again why sucrose or
benzoquinone
were chosen for the system suitability
test
in usp 643
certainly certainly so this this often
confuses so the toc test as i mentioned
it was introduced going to the united
states pharmacy in 1998 and it
actually replaced several other tests
and as i mentioned the usp work
committee were concerned to ensure that
any toc instrument
used to perform these tests should be
capable of successfully oxidizing
the range of organic materials to be
found in purified water and water
injection
so they devise a system suitability test
which challenges the toc
instrument with a relatively short chain
easy to oxidize
sucrose solution and a longer chain more
difficult to oxidize benzoquinone
solution
now as long as the toc instrument can
oxidize both solutions
equally well then it's deemed to be
suitable for testing
toc in purified water and water for
injection
thank you so much tony and we have one
more question from our audience
why does the japanese pharmacopoeia call
for
system suitability testing on sdbs
only good question and as i said earlier
the the scope
for the japanese pharmacopoeia excuse me
is broader
than that of the usp chapter on toc and
the japanese one
encompasses not only toc testing for
purified water and water injection
but also cleaning validation and the jp
recognizes that laboratory toc analyzers
primarily
are frequently used for both purified
water water injection testing
and cleaning validation where first of
all much higher levels of toc
may be present and much more complex
organic molecules such as cleaning
solutions may be present
so in order to ensure the toc instrument
can handle both
applications the jp challenges the toc
instrument to ensure that it can
successfully
oxidize and analyze the complex and
difficult to oxidize
sdbs solution now as long as the
analyzer can successfully recover more
than 90
of the toc from the fpvs solution
then the analyzer is deemed to be
suitable for both purified water
and water for injection testing as well
as cleaning validation
tony i want to thank you again for your
time today and for your important
research and i also want to thank lab
roots and our sponsor beckman coulter
life sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
and before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time
of registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care and stay
healthy bye bye everyone